let's face it it's not always easy to
understand everything you read in the
Bible with 66 books and more than 700
thousand words the Bible can generate a
lot of questions if you'd like answers
to your Bible questions you've come to
the right place now here's your host
pastor Doug Batchelor president and
Speaker of amazing facts
welcome listening friends to Bible
answers live would you like to hear an
amazing fact throughout history Jews
from around the world have sought to
have their remains laid to rest in
Jerusalem this has created a huge
challenge for the city sprawling
cemeteries that are unable to keep up
with a demand since they can no longer
spread out and they can't go up the only
other option was to go down in a big way
since 2014 a team has been tunneling
into the stone under Jerusalem's largest
cemetery to create a new vast
underground burial site when completed
it'll contain about 23,000 graves in a
series of interconnected hallways that
span over half a mile
the massive underground beehive cemetery
with its state-of-the-art lighting
elevators and ventilation systems will
cost about 57 million dollars devout
Jews believe the Scriptures teach that
the Messiah will someday come to the
Mount of Olives and so they want a
resting place nearby for the
resurrection day did you know the Bible
teaches the Messiah has already made his
first trip to the Mount of Olives
stay with us friends were going to learn
more as amazing facts brings you this
edition of Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
our phone lines are now open if you have
a Bible related question call us at one
eight hundred
804 sixty three seventy to ninety seven
now let's join our host pastor Doug
Batchelor and our co-host pastors Jean
Ross Bible answers live and we are live
if you have a Bible related question or
some question about living the Christian
life we will search the word together
and find answers God's promises search
and you will find you'd like to call in
with your Bible question tonight
beginning of the program a lot of room
for phone calls just pick up your phone
give us a call and here's the number
again eight hundred four six three seven
two nine seven of course it's a free
phone call and if you call and you don't
to have someone pick up right away just
hang on there they'll get to your call
eight hundred four six three seven two
nine seven probably some question you've
got about the Bible or living the
Christian life someone else is thinking
the same thing we always have some
original questions every night here's a
number again eight hundred four six
three seven two ninety seven my name is
Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross good
evening friends and pastor Doug once
again let's stop the word of prayer your
Father in Heaven we thank you that we
have this time to open up your word and
study together we want to ask your
blessing upon this program be with those
listening Lord and may we come to a
clearer understanding of the Bible
before we ask this in Jesus name Amen
amen
well pastor I give him the program by
talking about a very popular place to be
buried over there in Jerusalem and a lot
of history associated with Jerusalem and
of course the Jewish people and it's
getting a little crowded there to get
your burial plots so they coming up with
some creative ideas to pack more people
into that vicinity surrounding Jerusalem
yeah I remember the first time I went to
Jerusalem and I stood on the Mount of
Olives that seems like a quarter of it
is tombstones and then you get around on
the outskirts and
part of Jerusalem and it says the vast
cemetery and you know there are about 16
million Jews around the world and all of
them believe there's value in being
buried in or around Jerusalem because of
the Jewish faith Orthodox Jews they
don't cremate so it takes a little more
space obviously and and they're just
plumb they can't keep up with the demand
and so actually a man that had to drive
by one of these cemeteries every day he
saw it kept getting bigger and bigger he
said this isn't good for the landscape
and it it takes away from the living and
he was a tunneling engineer he said we
need to just build something underground
Jerusalem of course is famous for being
honeycombed in the rocks the limestone
with with tombs already and he said like
let's just let's take a great big
beehive Cemetery underneath the existing
cemetery and you can't see the pictures
on the radio but I'll tell you you can
look online and it is massive just think
about it half a mile long it's a long
way to walk through a cemetery above
ground and so they're taking this very
seriously and they've got holes all up
the wall just like the little cubicles
where you see the the nursery and a
beehive and they think this will keep
them for 25 more years and then they'll
run out of space again so it is really
something but people have actually
misunderstood now the reason that many
Jews want to be buried around Jerusalem
especially the Mount of Olives is based
on a prophecy you find in Zechariah 14
verse 4 speaking of the Messiah in the
end of the world it says in that day his
feet will stand on the Mount of Olives
that faces Jerusalem it's just over the
valley from Jerusalem and from the Mount
of Olives you get the very best view of
the Temple Mount and so they thought
Messiah is coming here that's where we
want to be but you know that prophecy in
Zechariah was fulfilled about 600 years
later maybe it's about 500 years later
when Jerusalem when Jesus came into
Jerusalem
and it says he went down from the Mount
of Olives in the multitude and the
disciples began to praise God for His
mighty work saying blessed is the king
who comes in the name of the Lord they
declared him to be the Messiah way back
then 2,000 years ago as he came down the
Mount of Olives
it's in the Bible referred to as the
triumphal entry and so there are a
number of Jews Kristen weren't
Christians back then those were all Jews
who believed he was the Messiah few days
later he died on a cross and they
weren't sure what was happening but then
he rose again and so yeah would be kind
of nice to have a front-row seat of the
Resurrection on the Mount of Olives when
Jesus comes but it really doesn't matter
where you're buried as long as you're
ready for his coming
now when Jesus talked about his second
coming and signs of his second coming
guess where he did that on the Mount of
Olives so and you read that Matthew 24
as he sat on the Mount of Olives the
disciples came to him privately saying
tell us when will these things be what
will be the sign of your coming and the
end of the world and so not only did he
ride down that mountain where they
declared him the king from that mount
and he talked about when he comes the
next time and his feet touched the Mount
of Olives when the Messiah comes back so
the Jews are right about that the
Messiah's feet will touch the Mount of
Olives it'll be the second coming of the
Lord and he foretold that now that of
course takes place not just when he
catches the Saints up but at the end of
the 1,000 years you may want to
understand that subject friends and we
have a free offer that'll tell you more
about the Lord's return we have a book
called the last night on earth and we'll
be happy to send this to anybody who
calls and asks it's all about the second
coming of Jesus certain events that
occur when Jesus comes again to receive
this book call our resource phone line
that is eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven and just asked for
the book called the last night on earth
and we'll be able to send it to anybody
who calls and asks and if you have a
Bible question the phone line here to
the studio is 800 four six three seven
two nine seven I'm going to repeat that
so grab
something to write down the number 804
six three seven two nine seven or eight
hundred God says looks like we have
phone lines open this is a good time to
pick up your phone and give us a call
and we'll try and get your Bible
question on the program tonight with
that I think we're ready to go to the
first caller this evening we have
Daniela this thing in California Daniela
welcome to the program
hello Daniela you're on the air
hi and your question tonight my question
is how can God be in the past present
and future and especially in the past
all right that's a good question now how
old are you Daniella Mauro I tell you're
asking a very big question for a
nine-year-old it's you're asking how can
God exist in all the different times and
especially in the past well you know
there's some things about time we don't
really understand God in the Bible has
taken prophets forward in time and shown
them things that will happen and vision
and they happened exactly like God told
them God takes some prophets back in
time he does this in Revelation chapter
12 with John when he shows him the war
that took place in heaven where Satan
made war against Jesus and he shows him
things that happened in the past God
because he's so big
he can actually live in the future he
can see the future he can see the past
there's nothing that God doesn't know he
knows everything that will happen and
everything that has happened and he can
show it to people so it is a mystery
that we can't explain there was a very
famous scientist named Albert Einstein
and he found out that you can actually
travel through time a little bit into
the future if you could go faster than
the speed of light
so we've just we're just beginning to
learn a few things about time and how it
works but you know hundred years ago
Danijela people didn't understand how
cellphones would work they didn't know
how TV
would work how in the world could
pictures go through the air and end up
in someone else's box now we understand
it we don't understand now how God can
control time but someday we will but
that's a good question
thank you thank you for calling vanilla
and our next call a sherry listening in
Michigan sherry welcome to the program
hi hi oh okay what I want to know is um
I wanted to know what cane
oops I think we lost sherry there and
looks like we've having some technical
difficulties here with our phone lines
friends if you have a Bible question
give us a call especially those of you
who are on hold looks like we might have
dropped the call so give us a call back
and we'll try and get your Bible
question on the program tonight the
number here to the studio is 800 four
six three seven two nine seven again
there's 800 four six three seven two
nine seven again if you're were on hold
and you had called in with your Bible
question and suddenly the phone was
disconnected looks like we might be
having some technical challenges give us
a call again and we'll try and get your
Bible question on the program today so
let's see if we can get a few of those
callers back that we're on hold we
caná-- maybe give them just once if take
one live here you know I don't know if I
can take you just yet pastor Doug we've
got to give them just a few more
usually our calls go through an operator
here in the studio that just gets the
basic information and our callers are
generally pretty nice I thought what
would just take one hot off the air
there we got a caller all right he'll be
ready to go I think we have Melton
listening Melton or sherry welcome to
the program hi Holly
all right okay my question was we just
got cut off just a minute ago but my
question is when keen went out of the I
didn't feel after he killed Abel who
were these people were there any other
people on the earth besides Cain and
Abel well Adam and Eve of course had
other children if you read in Genesis 5
it tells us that Adam and Eve had son
plural and daughters and of course God
told Adam and Eve be fruitful and
multiply and their health and all the
reproductive hardware was working
perfectly and so Adam and Eve living
over 900 years probably had many many
children it only talks about the
firstborn to begin with which was Cain
Abel and then after Abel was killed it
talks about Seth
so Cain knowing that he was going to be
infamous among the other people in the
world for this murder
he said no men are gonna try and kill me
that's why he refers to other people
he's looking down the line he thinks
over time the people that multiply
they're gonna look upon me as the great
offender see what I'm saying and then he
ultimately Cain it says he took his wife
and he went east to the Land of Nod and
and his wife was probably one of his
sisters it had to be which I know sounds
strange but Adam technically married his
sister when you think about it I mean
Adam and Eve had the same Creator and we
do have a verse in Genesis chapter 5
verse 4 that says speaking of Adam and
Eve and he begat Seth this is after Ava
was was killed
it says the days of Adam were eight
hundred years then it says he had sons
and daughters so it's pretty clear there
that there were more than just the three
sons that Adam and Eve had so thank you
sherry hope that helps a little bit and
that tells you a little bit about who
some of the people were in the world
back then and our I appreciate your call
Mexico Lee is Sierras here welcome to
the program let's see if we can get see
aerobes looks like we lost that call
we're having some again holes just
dropping off here quite sure why that a
fast attack let's see if we can try a
different color here if you got dick cut
off tonight we're not we're apologize
don't know what happened but call us
back we are getting a couple calls
through so someone's working right well
let's try one more : I'm not quite sure
who this caller is yet so pastor day
you're gonna have to talk on here until
we get named up on the screen for those
of you who are listening we're alive and
sometimes we do have some challenges
with our calls that come in or don't
come in so we got to wait until they can
process it and get it up on the screen
here so we can see who's calling yeah by
the way you know we ought to be telling
people while we're waiting about oh they
can listen to a Bible answer live
archives at the website and we have not
only do we have the Bible answer live
program amazing facts has scores I bet
you we have over a hundred youtubes
mm-hmm that people can watch or sermons
we just created anew and last night it
had a wonderful Christmas program there
at the church and I think that's been
posted up on Facebook um and again we
like to remind people of taking a look
or go over to the amazing facts website
just amazing facts dot o-r-g there is
just a host of material there Bible
answer live programs that you can listen
to also a lot of videos a lot of written
material if you have questions and
different Bible doctrines you can
actually search search through all of
that and it's a great study resource in
addition to that we do have a free Bible
school and if you're interested in
studying further just take a look at the
amazing facts website and you can click
on the link that says the Bible School
got a brand-new set of lessons that
folks can go through and study this
gives you a wealth of bible information
in truth well we still work on the four
lines of precedent we don't have this
problem very often where we're
speechless because we're here to answer
questions and we've we've had something
happen where there's a gremlin the calls
come through we see them pop up and when
we go to take them they evaporate so if
you have a Bible question friends don't
give up on us give us another call and
we will take your your Bible question
you know pastor Ross and I just finished
doing a series in Washington DC or the
Washington DC area I should say and
called foundations of faith
and if you just type in foundations of
faith dot info you'll see that we did
nine presentations that talk about the
the Reformation and some of the areas
where the refere
nation needs to continue and so you may
want to just take a look at foundations
of faith and we got a lot of great
information there
I think we got a call ready here all
right let's go to our next caller and
we'll see is that somebody by the name
of er perhaps available hello are you on
the air caller on the air
hello yes you're all right you sorry we
don't have your name up on the screen so
I'm glad you responded we can hear you
hi jack and your question this evening
thank you for holding on yeah my
question is why wasn't the rapture ever
mentioned in the plan by any theologians
before the 20th century I mean look you
don't you know anything about it from
from at all until like the last part of
the 19th century and the 20th century
why just never ever was making well you
know you're you've got a you got a good
point because now the idea of the
rapture is that we're going to be caught
up to meet the Lord in the air that's in
the Bible in 1st Thessalonians where it
says you know the dead in Christ will
rise that the Lord will descend from
heaven with a shout the voice of the
Archangel the trumpet of God the dead in
Christ will be caught up that's what
they think of when they think of the
rapture when we're caught up to meet the
Lord but you ride the idea of a secret
rapture and people being left behind for
7 years of tribulation Christian's
historically always believed the
tribulation was before the second coming
the idea that the Second Coming happens
before the tribulation is a
comparatively new teaching and so you're
right on there Chuck sure yeah if you
have another question it's you know the
dead in Christ already was risen when
when he when he when he when he rose the
dead in Christ rose right to end you
know he walked around the
Brown people though he said those people
walked around at that time couldn't that
possibly be what they're talking about I
mean he already happened yeah well when
Jesus rose there was a group it doesn't
say that all the saints that slept there
were some that were raised because even
after yeah there was a small group that
Christ took to heaven because after
Jesus went to heaven after his
resurrection Paul still said the
resurrection was future and and if you
look in John chapter 11 when Martha said
lord if you'd been here my brother
wouldn't have died but even now I know
whatever you ask God will give you and
and Jesus said your brother will rise
and she said well I know he'll rise
again the last day they always believed
the resurrection was at the end of the
world which is correct and it says it's
with the second coming of the Lord
Paul said that in 1st Corinthians 15
that the dead in Christ rise at his
coming and so yeah the a lot of people
believe that you know the resurrection
happens as soon as you die but it the
general resurrection is at the second
coming of the Lord
yeah we get our new bodies it says in
1st Corinthians 15 in the moment and the
twinkling of an eye at the last Trump
that's when we're gonna be raised again
and yeah we appreciate your call you
know we do have a book yeah yeah I was
gonna mention ideal for the subject
called
anything but secret and we'll be able to
send this book to anybody who calls an
ass check this might be a great resource
that you'd like to look at it's free all
your life did he just call and ask for
it then I'm gonna call his 808 three
five six seven four seven and as for the
book called anything but secret all
about the second coming of Christ and
also talking about the resurrection I'll
be happy again to send this to anybody
who calls and asks friends it looks like
we've fixed up at least for the time
being our phone system that gave us a
hard time just a few moments ago so if
you have a Bible question this is a good
time to give us a call the number is 800
four six three seven two nine seven
again that's 800 God says 800
four six three seven two nine seven if
you don't get through right away just
stay on the phone and we will try to get
to your question all right one more time
here it is 800 for six three seven two
nine seven great time to give us a call
with your Bible question our next Holy's
John John welcome to the program thank
you I'm proud to be on I appreciate it
in your question tonight yes and I'm
traveling so I'm doing it from memory so
I'm not going to do it justice but
there's a verse that says even the
crumbs from the master's table the dogs
eat or don't feed your pearls to swine I
don't understand what that means could
you help me please yeah but I will but I
think you're probably mixing two
different parables oh there's a parable
where a woman well it's not a parable
it's a true story where a woman comes to
Jesus and said you know can you heal my
daughter she was a syrophoenician woman
that means she was from the northern
region up around tyre and sidon and
Jesus she's a Gentile she's not a Jew
and Jesus said something that's really
troubled a lot of people he said it's
not appropriate to take the children's
food and give it to the dogs that's
Matthew chapter 15 verse 26 is the
reference there right and she responded
but yeah even the dogs get the crumbs
that fall from the children's table yeah
Jesus a great is your faith your
daughter is healed he was testing her
faith and then there's the other verse
where you said that it says that in I
believe it's in first Peter where it
talks about the the pig that was washed
has returned a wallowing in the mire
the dog returns to its vomit and that's
really that's you know talking about a
dog again but it's a different parable
Peter's quoting a parable of Solomon
where he talks about somebody that you
know they're not converted in their
heart and they may outwardly do the
right thing for a while but they just
run back to the Pigpen and then also you
have the reference there in Matthew
chapter 7 verse 6 where it says do not
give that which is holy to the dogs or
cast your pearls before swine that
be the one using the one yes yes yes
that's it thank you so much
absolutely and yeah we appreciate your
your question tonight and if you're
interested we'd be happy to send you our
free resource tonight called last night
on earth just call and we'll be some
that to you then I'm gonna call to get
that free resources eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and the
phone line here to the studio is eight
hundred four six three seven two nine
seven and we have David he's listening
David welcome to the program David
you're on the air
hey David I think where you got your
radio on in the background there's a
time delay you're on the air you know
what I think we just lost David
hopefully our phone line system all
start working correctly here just a
minute
let's try Harry Harry welcome to Bible
answers live you're on the air we are
thanks for calling in any reference to
tithing in the Bible except for in
Hebrews 7 I believe it's either I
believe it's verse 7 and 8 or maybe 8
and 9 and I know it just seems like
every quarters of megachurches today and
a lot of even our own church they really
emphasize tithing and I've always had a
problem with that because it's not
actually mentioned in the Bible accepted
in groups and I know I'm just wonder
what's your take on that well no no
we're not at all bothered I think it's a
great question and we're glad you asked
first of all tie this is first mentioned
well I think it goes back to Genesis 14
21 Abraham gave tithes to Melchizedek
he gave a tenth and that's what the word
tired man you're right in it says but he
gave him a tenth so all right let's move
on then and then Jacob Jacob said Lord
if you bring me safely back
to the promised land cuz he was going to
get a wife in the land of mesopotamia
said tenth of all I get I'll give to you
there that's the word tithe simply means
the tenth it's the same word then if you
go to Malachi chapter 4
I'm sorry Malachi chapter 3 God says
you've robbed me yet you say how have we
robbed you and God says in tithes and
offerings and so he says bring all the
tithes into the storehouse and prove me
and see if I don't open for you the
windows of heaven so the plan God had in
the Old Testament for supporting the
priesthood is one-tenth of the increase
of their fields and their orchards and
their vineyards they would bring to the
sanctuary to the storehouses and it
would help feed the Levites that then
were ministering to the people
throughout the land now the Levites were
not only priests they were often also
something of the they they were medical
missionaries they were the judges they
they had a number of responsibilities
but if you don't mind holding on for
just a moment more we are going to take
a break in just a minute and we can give
you some more verses on tithe of course
you've also got that passage where it
talks about the tithe is holy unto the
Lord and when it was set aside for the
Levites and there are some New Testament
passages to so stand by friends we're
going to come back and tin you this
question we do have some lines open if
you have a Bible question here it is
free phone call eight hundred four six
three seven two nine seven please don't
go away we're coming back
[Music]
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
I really wanted to start a new
devotional habit but life got in the way
next thing I know we're month into the
new year and I'm like what's the point
of starting then I saw 365 amazing
answers to big Bible questions each day
is a single study so you can start
anywhere on any day and not miss a thing
their crisp clear and enlightening get
yours today
by calling 855-578-6767
[Music]
every bible question you have answered
moves you one step closer to the
fullness of God's will for your life so
what are you waiting for get the answers
you need for a fuller richer more
confident life you're listening to Bible
answers live this broadcast is a
previously recorded episode if you'd
like answers to your Bible related
questions on the air please call us next
Sunday between 7 p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific
time to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evenings
program call 888-814-3923 phone call you
get a free chance ask any bible question
or a question about living the Christian
life and we'll do our best to give you a
Bible answer my name is Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross pastor like just
before the break we were talking to
chuck about the question on tithing
where is that mention in the Bible and
what are the principles connected with
that before we move on to the next call
we didn't have a chance to actually
mention a resource that we have an
amazing facts that talks about finance
and the Christian it's called in god we
trust' and we'll be happy to send it out
to anybody wanting to learn more about
our responsibility as Christians with
reference to finance again the number to
call if you would like to receive this
free offer is 883 five six seven four
seven and you can ask for the study
guide called in god we trust' and we'll
be happy to send that out to anybody who
calls and asks yeah we told check that
there is of course a verse there several
verses in the New Testament but one is
where Jesus says in Matthew 23:23 he
said you pay tithes of mint and anise
and cumin and but you omit the weightier
matters of
justice mercy and faith these you ought
to have done and not leave the other
undone he says do not leave the tithe
pain undone but make sure you don't
forget the priority of justice mercy and
faith and then yeah I think he also
mentioned Hebrews and that's true tithe
as mentioned there as well but in the
New Testament they did a lot more than
just give tithe a they would sometimes
sell houses and lands and and invest
them in spreading the gospel so there's
just a few verses for you and best thing
to do would be sending for the study
guide it is filled with the references
thank you for your question okay Mexico
love that we have is Charles and
listening in Alabama Charles welcome to
the program let's see if we can get it
again
Charles Charles in Alabama are you there
yeah are you yes we can hear you okay
I'm going to ask whether unusual
question and student I was introduced to
a book and I have no idea what to make
of it and want to know have you ever
heard of it and if so what's your
opinion it's called the urantia book and
that spelled you are a in CIA is it
curious Urata is it connected with the
Bible or Christianity well get that's
not a question of what it's claims to be
Christian base to have their own version
of Adam and Eve their own version of
Jesus I mean but it it takes to be Bible
and basically the Liberty misinterpreted
from what little bit I've read about it
so who wrote it well that's the unusual
thing those supposedly knows human
author it was they don't like to say it
but it was what we would call a channel
they don't say that they say was a
miraculous book the believers in it but
I was curious do you would have heard of
it you know while you were talking I was
just looking at
a little bit online to see if there's
more information about it and it's it is
defined as some kind of a spiritual or
philosophical type book believed to
originate in the Chicago area somewhere
between 1924 and 1955 so that's not very
long ago but of course there's no
reference in scripture or it's kind of
got some just looking at it here it's
got some questionable teachings and
doctrine that really contradict what the
Bible says yeah we on the program here
we take the position that the Bible is
the Word of God mm-hmm and yet we use it
as the foundation Jesus said the
Weizmann builds on the rock of his word
it's not what other people write and you
know the the writings of men come and go
and they're kind of like the sands of
time so the Word of God is the the rock
that has endured the test so if you do
have a question about the Bible or the
Christian life well since there's a
statistic I read ninety-eight percent of
the quotes in the book come from the
Bible so that's why I was curious what
what your take on it was but I
appreciate the answer yeah
never never read the book before so I
probably can't be a very fair judge of
how to relate it but it sounds dubious
just from the information we can find
online you know we do have a book about
the Bible kind of talking about the
authorship of the Bible how that the
Prophet spoke of all being moved by the
Holy Spirit and how the Bible is being
preserved it's called the ultimate
resource and we'll be happy to send this
to anybody this will build your faith in
the Word of God that you can trust the
Bible the number to call for that is
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you can answer the book
called the ultimate resource it's all
about the Bible I think you'll find it
very encouraging our next caller Susan
and Susan welcome to the program you're
on the air yes hello my question is
about myself I had terminated a
pregnancy about 35 years ago and since
then I've been
again I've asked for forgiveness in in
my heart I just don't feel forgiven um I
don't know if that's my own lack of
being able to forgive myself and I'm
sure there are a lot of women out there
that struggle with this and I'm just
wondering if they're possibly any
answers for me to help know that God is
forgiving me well first of all the only
forget the only sin that is not
forgivable is the unpardonable sin and
what you're describing is not classified
as the unpardonable sin that means it is
forgivable
now when Jesus forgives your sin he
doesn't say I'm gonna give you a 90
percent forgiving and forgiveness or 75
percent forgiveness it's a hundred
percent you read if we confess our sins
and this is first John chapter one he is
faithful and just to forgive us our sins
and to cleanse us from all
unrighteousness and so he completely
forgives us Isaiah says you know though
your sins be like scarlet they'll be
whitest snow though they're red like
crimson they will be as wool and he
tries to use words to describe complete
purity and so you know and this is what
David prayed about when he confessed his
sin this is that God washed me with
hyssop and I will be clean I'll be
whiter than snow you know it's always
encouraging when you read for example in
Hebrews chapter 11 the great chapter we
call it the heroes of faith and you read
about the different characters that's
listed there Bible characters and then
you read there so in the Old Testament
and you can see the experiences they
went through and some of the sins that
they guilty of and yet they confess
their sins and they are forgiven and now
God views them as heroes of faith
because they were faithful to him you
got examples of Samson it was one of the
heroes of faith David of course and you
know you've got Rahab the harlot and it
just lists all of these Moses guilty of
murder that's right he killed some days
it was yeah you knew you might not only
was David guilty of the death of Uriah
he was guilty of the death of the
soldiers that were
with Uriah that night in that conflict
and David was guilty for the death of
the child and so God forgave David right
and this is you know the same kind of
principle I think you're asking about
yes yes it is yes so you you know you've
repented the Bible promises if we
confess our sins if we repent we tell
God we're sorry that he will forgive us
and he looks upon you as though you've
never sinned know if the devil keeps
waving your sin in your face you just
say a lot of Jesus has forgiven me and I
embrace that and don't let him keep God
God forgives your sins it says he casts
your sins into the depths of the sea and
you know don't forget the Lord said if
you have faith you can say to the
mountain be plucked up and it'll be cast
into the sea and then he says your sins
are cast into the sea it's really a
mountain of sin that's cast into the sea
by faith in Christ and he puts up a
no-fishing the sign God is not gonna
doesn't want you fishing up your sins
he's forgiven okay thank you very much
you're welcome Sarah god bless next
Kohli's bill listening washington bill
welcome to the program oh thank you hi
Doug and I Ross when things get settled
down there and then the Lord creates a
new heaven and a new earth and Mike my
question is will they be unclean animals
and the new heaven and new earth because
the Lord says the pig is unclean you
know you're supposed to touch it the
lobsters and all those bottom fish and
everything there'll be no more see so I
wouldn't need those and what about the
vultures they wouldn't need those birds
of prey anymore will they be unclean
animals in the new earth well will there
be thorns in the new earth thorns and
thistles came out as a result of sin
there will be flowers there probably be
roses but there won't be thorns on the
roses there probably will be animals
that like you know some of the
scavengers but they're not going to be
scavengers because the Bible says the
lion is going to eat grass the lion is
still there but he's changed so the pigs
will not be unclean because there
it's different the vultures will not be
unclean their diets different and so I
don't know pastor oz what you think but
I think God's can have all kinds of
interesting animals they're just not
eating each other right well you know
also talking about the earth created in
the beginning it talks about all of
these different kind of animals I think
the reason between clean and unclean is
that they need to be a clear distinction
between which of the animals could be
used for sacrifices you could never
sacrifice an unclean animal so
distinction was made and then after the
flood God permitted the clean animals to
be eaten because there was a shortage of
you know vegetables on the earth or
grains or whatever it might be but the
animal in and of itself you know all of
us have for many of us have pet dogs a
dog would technically be unclean some of
them just they have some wonderful
character traits that we appreciate so I
don't think there's not gonna be any of
those kind of animals in heaven sure
yeah it says they're gonna be wolf
that's in the dog family there you go
the wolf will lie down and even says a
snake will be there it says the child
will play on the whole of the venomous
snake so I think the answer is yes there
will be animals that we call unclean now
they're of course unclean for food or
for sacrifice all the animals that were
either carnivorous or scavengers were
unclean and but I'm sure we'll be all
kinds of animals they just will not hurt
or destroy they won't eat each other in
the new earth good question I appreciate
that yeah you did that answer your
question yes yes you know that that is
fine I'm hoping snakes will not fly but
I don't know well if they do you won't
have to worry about it because they'll
be harmless in heaven they're not gonna
nothing is going to hurt and they had
serpents in the Garden of Eden and until
the devil possessed the serpent you know
serpents were just another creature God
made and the debt you know the devil can
possess an animal the devil possessed
pigs in the New Testament and God
possessed a donkey in the Old Testament
so there's nothing wrong with the pigs
of the donkey or the serpent it's just
that it's the spirits that possess them
hey thank you very much good question
Mexico lays donna.donna listening for
Marilyn Donna you on the air
okay good evening pastor Doug and pastor
Don hi my question is can you tell me
who the 24 elders are that are around
the throne of God in heaven yeah yeah
you know you took referencing revelation
chapter 4 we have a description of the
heavenly throne room and it talks about
God the Father seated upon the throne
and talks about the four living
creatures that make up the throne and
then it says these 24 elders that were
surrounding the throne there's been two
suggestions as to the identity they're
24 hours the one I think has more
scriptural support the idea being that
those who were resurrected at the time
of Christ's resurrection that they
ascended up with Jesus to heaven which
the Bible does indicate occurred some
say well maybe they the 24 elders but
there's another line of thought that I
think is more biblical and that is that
the 24 elders would be the
representatives of the other unfallen
worlds now you remember in the story of
Joe says that the sons of God presented
themselves before God and Satan came and
God said Satan where did you come from
Oh from walking up and down on the earth
so Psalms talks about the Lord reigning
before his elders gloriously and so
there's other biblical references to the
idea of the elders represent being the
representatives probably Adam would have
been amongst them had he not fallen and
sort of turned over the leadership of
the earth or at least the representation
of the earth to the devil but Christ has
now earned the right again to be the
representative he's referred to as the
second Adam in the New Testament yeah
and if if you look in the Old Testament
David when he set up his kingdom and
even during the time of Solomon
they had 24,000 people that were set
aside ie to work in service in a
rotation in the temple and there were
leaders of that 24,000 so they were like
24 elders that he had that to help with
the ministry of the sanctuary so it's
even reminding us that in God's heavenly
temple there's these leaders that
represent other worlds just like David
had and Salah
their earthly temple okay if if Jesus
isn't in heaven and he represents the
earth now would he also be Jesus our
Savior in one of the outers now all the
other elders and revelations surrounded
Christ so that would be 25 including
Jesus so Jesus is the the it he's God
the son he is the not only the leader
and representative of this world but he
we were the only world where the creator
is our representative so to speak
because of course Christ created us he
redeemed us he is worthy of worship he
is the second Adam in that sense but he
is also God okay very good I appreciate
your answer thanks for watching next
holy is Deen listening in Michigan
Dean welcome to the program good evening
and god bless you both evening thank you
for calling and your question well okay
this has been on my mind for a long time
in the time that Jesus walked the earth
this is a three-part question how long
was it generation how many years
probably 40 years as you want me to give
you reasons for that from the Bible or
you just want to take my word for it you
know I take your word for it and today
today I believe it's 20 years as a
generation well yeah that has nothing to
do with biblical reasons but yeah the
people say 20 years now because
typically a person gets to be between 18
and 25 is when they they get old enough
to enter the armed services to vote and
they're they're driving insurance goes
down 25 is it your brain so the measure
generation when people start families
typically somewhere between the 20 and
25 it used to be people got married you
know earlier in the century people got
married at 19 and 20 and now the
marriage age has been pushed back okay
um so when Jesus days his uh prediction
of when his return was he
in that generation shall we see the Son
of God come back in a cloud now having
said that and I'm just going back to
Israel when Israel was founded in 48
it's been over 40 years now this is
where I'm conflicting with you're saying
it's 40 years well it's been past 40
years well let's talk about that Jesus
yeah at the beginning of that prophecy
the disciples asked Jesus what do you
mean there will not be one stone left
upon another in the temple see they were
just showing Jesus why we've got the
greatest national temple of any country
massive stones that were brought by
Solomon and King Herod and Jesus said
don't you see these things is not going
to be left here one stone upon another
that will not be thrown down and well
let me finish Jesus makes that prophecy
he makes that prophecy in 30 AD 40 years
later exact Bible generation in 70 AD
the Romans destroyed the temple and they
did not leave one stone upon another
exactly what Jesus said so that's what
he's referring to he wasn't referring to
the re-establishment of Israel no no in
that generation after Israel that the
second coming of Christ would come no
they asked for a shin shall see no no
that generation shall see him I
respectfully disagree the the disciples
are asking Jesus three questions if you
read in Matthew 24 they came to Jesus
after he made this outrageous statement
that there wouldn't be one stone left
upon another this is Matthew 24 and I
forget the exact first pastor Russ and
they asked him when will these things be
what will be the sign of your coming in
the end of the world so the first
question is when will these things be
what things not one stone left upon
another in the temple so part of Jesus
answer is answering their first question
when will the temple be destroyed when
will a Jerusalem be conquered you
remember Jesus going to the cross he
said one of Israel don't weep for me
weep for yourselves because the day is
coming well they'll say blessed is the
that did not bear and your enemies will
head you in on every side and that
happened when the Romans surrounded
Jerusalem a generation later and
destroyed the city so several of
Christ's prophecies were warnings to the
Jews of his day that before a generation
went by Jerusalem was going to be
completely leveled and it happened so
the other part of his answer was what
will be signs of your coming the end of
the world he said well there'll be
earthquakes they'll be wars in different
places but the end is not yet so the
generation phrase is I think
specifically dealing with the
destruction of Jerusalem okay all right
that cleared it up okay thank you very
much good question I appreciate it thank
you very much Nina
Mexico Lee's Raymond listening Michigan
Raymond welcome to the program good
thank you for calling my question is why
why does the inner race as this suffer I
know we live in a fallen world and I
know that Jesus Christ suffered on the
on the cross but we did have pretty much
taken a bus away from me suffering or we
just live in a fallen world and we're
going to suffer anyways well there there
are trials God the Bible says Jesus said
sunshine and rain comes to everybody the
good and the evil we're in a world where
this planet has been kidnapped by an
Archfiend better known as Satan or the
devil he was once a powerful angel he
rebelled against God he has claimed the
world as his because Adam and Eve listen
to the devil instead of God God said do
not do this and the devil said go ahead
and they listened to the devil and it
says in Romans chapter 6 whoever you
obey that's whose servants you are and
so the devil even Jesus referred to the
devil as the Prince of this world and so
Satan has brought all kinds of misery
and problems in this world Jesus said
the devil is the one who's the author of
the
and so Christ came because he wants us
to have abundant life he doesn't want us
to live in fear he doesn't want us to
you know Jesus always said do not fear
he said I'm coming to give you peace he
said I want my joy to remain in you so
peace and joy and the abundant life
begin when we come to Christ now that
doesn't mean Christians never suffer
because they do but it's a whole lot
easier when you know it's temporary and
you know Peter said that and Paul said
you know our suffering is working
something in us that kind of purifies
but Christians can look beyond this
world the Bible ends by saying God's
taking away all tears from their eyes
revelation 20:1 there'll be no more
death or pain and so you know we're
looking forward to a world where there
is no longer any more death no more
suffering and all things are made new
but until Christ comes and we get our
bodies that don't grow old we do have to
grapple with that you still there yes
you know we have a we've got a DVD that
you would probably enjoy that explains
this I think you can watch it free
online it's called cosmic conflict
anyone out there if you want a better
understand why is there sin and
suffering in the world just go to
youtube go to the amazing facts Channel
either one type in cosmic conflict watch
that DVD and I think it's about 45
minutes but it's very clearly animated
Illustrated to help people understand
that and thank you very much for your
question next holy is Stephen in
Kentucky hi Stephen
hello hi how can we help you okay I have
a question in regards to the seventh-day
adventists and the Christmas celebration
and you have to understand I'm all over
the board on this and anyway how how
does the seventh-day adventists justify
Christmas but there's really no emphasis
on the on God's feast days all right
well first of all the the laws about the
the feast days are very different from
the laws about you know the seventh-day
Sabbath and I you know I don't want to
answer this from the perspective of one
particular denomination you asked about
Christmas to begin with I think most
Christians know at this point that Jesus
was very likely not born the
twenty-fifth of December it seems from
the Bible that he was born sometime in
the fall September so maybe August the
reason we know that is we know when
Jesus died he died in the spring we know
he began his ministry at his thirtieth
birthday that's Luke chapter 3 Jesus
ministered three and a half years till
he died during the Passover so if you
want to find out when he was born you
count back three and a half years from
the spring and you end up in the fall so
Jesus was not born December the
Shepherd's were not out in the fields in
Jerusalem but that doesn't mean that as
Christians if people are remembering or
reading about or telling the story of
Christ's birth that we can't make the
most of that and say yes it's a
wonderful thing that Jesus came as a
baby or the gift of God and and the
condescension of Christ and coming into
our world that's a wonderful thing
that's something very different from
keeping the Jewish feasts and you know
if a person wants to keep one of the
Jewish feasts is no law against that
Paul said if one man wants to regard the
day to the Lord let him regard it to the
Lord
but don't judge your brother who doesn't
and so we believe that in Colossians
chapter 2 the annual Sabbath's like
Passover Feast of Trumpets and so forth
and those holidays were nailed to the
cross now we do have a book we can send
you and it's called feast days and
Sabbath's or we got baptized paganism -
either one and it'll help answer that
question for you and give you just a
little more information that's probably
you know I'm coming out with a new book
right now
that's not printed yet but it will be
before the end of the year on the feast
days should Christians deeply Jewish
feast days we get that question a lot
and if anyone wants to know more about
that we'll be having that book available
soon not quite off the press yet friends
you can tell we've reached the end of
our question time we still have some
exciting announcements coming but if you
didn't get your question on tonight's
program we got well in our live again
next week and we look forward to
visiting with you this time of year
people are thinking about supporting
different Christian ministries as you
consider that if you've been blessed by
Bible answers live go to the website let
us know and you can click the donate
bubble button keep us on the air
god bless until we study next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
life's a curious thing I mean just when
things seem under control
wham you're hit with something new your
marriage is good
suddenly it's on the brink of divorce
the jobs great and then it's gone and so
is your life savings you feel healthy
any doctor gives the bad news what's
coming next you could look to the stars
but they don't have the answers but this
does the prophecy Study Bible by amazing
facts
this Bible special it's 27 personal
study guides lead you on a life-changing
journey through God's Word to discover
real answers to life's questions from
health and relationships to family and
the future the hopes in here get your
amazing facts prophecy study Bible today
by calling
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWF ag0 RG and sign
up for our free Bible study course and
make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at
[Music]